bonjour et bienvenue sur le studio
diagonale tv à juin 2016 championnat de
france d'échecs huitième ronde une ronde
mais alors extraordinaire que ce soit
dans les nationales mixtes ou le crs
national féminin et aujourd'hui je suis
donc avec natacha bonjour la tâche après
bonjour c'est fait alors aujourd'hui tu
avais une partie très importante puisque
après les rondes précédentes et mais tu
t'es retrouvé quatre points d'affilée et
à un demi point du leader ce film signé
alors aujourd'hui tu nous a sorti une
autre partie là là quelle partie
extraordinaire façon de rire tu la
connais bien audrey important on a déjà
joué quelques fois oui et c'est vrai que
c'est une chose assez redoutable
j'appréhendais rebeu à partie mais pas
comme ici je suis pas inquiet par mon
frère et moi et ma soeur et on dit fais
toi plaisir vas-y qu'elle attend je vais
avant tout d'accords donc tu t'es pas
pour trop poser de questions sur le
titre le fait et c'est non c'est tu as
essayé de jouer la partie au mieux 2 oui
oui ça sans y penser quoi bon nature le
stress du camp sera provident a
dernièrement mais encore comme disait
mon grand frère
le titre est encore long il ya quand
même deux parties à jouer oui j'ai
encore deux joueuses j'avais encore deux
joueuses redoutables a rencontré sur ce
serait se poser la question beaucoup de
retours voilà bien sûr tout à fait en
fait avait déjà quatre victoires
d'affilée ce qui fit classe a tant fait
une cinquième a envie d'en membres avant
de parler de ça quand même et de
peut-être la dernière ronde demain
rapidement parce qu'il faut voir aussi
que tu être te reposer simplement voir
cette partie et puis tu vas me dire
qu'on risque ce que tu as ce que tu as
vécu l'un sur l échiquier parce qu'alors
qu'elle partie mes aïeux vous allez voir
ça donc c'est parti tuer les blancs face
à andré a inventé ce coup donc tu es en
ce moment la deuxième
du national à un demi point de ce film
est à égalité avec almira skripchenko et
donc tu joues pour essayer au moins de
rester en tête et jouer tes chances à la
dernière ronde c'est parti avec eux
quatre bons soit c'est ton cou aux
favoris oui le seul coup n'y a rien à
dire
c'est simple tu t'attendais à ça dans le
championnat d' andré a joué la française
à deux reprises donc j'ai dû préparer
quelque chose contre ça française et
aussi je m'attendais peut-être à sa
sicilienne j'ai préparé les deux mais je
mettais plus focalisés sur la française
d'accord a oui donc c'est une demi
surprise on va dire lors une démission
qui domine surprise donc la veille f3
tranquille cavalli c6 elle joue ça aussi
l'an dernier j'avais joué au cices une
vie qu'elle avait gagné je pensais
qu'elle allait laquelle avait répété à
laquelle elle est répétée
elle peut se dire je les jouais elle a
donc préparé quelque chose oui mais elle
aurait très bien pu elle aussi préparé
améliorer ce qu'on avait joué voilà on
s'est toujours le un petit peu le bluff
de début de partie
oui voilà donc foulée cinq grosses au
liban on a vu beaucoup trop son lumière
dans ce dans ce championnat
c'est une façon de jouer la sicilienne
plus positionnelle que de jouer des
quatre tout de suite oui donc
l'ouverture comme une autre mais un peu
à la mode en ce moment
cavalier f6 donc la tacc le pion aux 4
et simplement talent et se tient
une pièce g6 ça c'est beaucoup c'est le
coup joué on peut jouer plein d'autres
coups en fait un push composent ou des
six bourgeois aussi c'est un peu joué un
peu n'importe quoi non dans cette
position là enfin avec elle et ses 6 qui
avait six mois je connais g6 oui j 6 e
cours normal d'accord h3 pourquoi je
crois parce que tu pourrais faire petit
rock le tout de suite ici
en fait l'idée c'est de pousser le pion
au no 5 et d'enlever la case g4 aux
cavaliers voilà je vous jouez 500 permet
de cavaler g4 qui aurait attaquerez le
pion d'ailleurs donc voilà probablement
ça nous laisse où j'ai six des sept
l'accord des cinq et aux cinq d'accord
donc ça veut dire que là les noirs vont
revenir en g8 parce que lecavalier ici
n'a pas mis case là il a pas de case là
puisque ce qu'avait dit contrôler le
fameux courage 3 juin les black cats et
sylvia en scène qu on a toujours le coup
g4g 4 et le cas van in africa le cnrd
les prix par le fou ici ici il ya le
pion ici du coup à noyelles et ya encore
et oui alors aurait pu alors et puis
quand même encore un cavalier au travail
âge simple confort était possible et
dans ce cas peut-être des 4 ou
d'étouffement ou peut-être fou prend c6
ou faut prendre ces six d'abord détroit
ensuite à las vegas en fait pas la cave
et h5 et vraiment il mal placé voilà il
est mal placé il est triste en matière
d'accord d'accord donc ici eux cinq
cavaliers 8 donc déjà bon c'est quand
même un aveu de problématiques parce
qu'on revient à la maison mais
apparemment c'est une ligne qui se fout
coin c'est quand même un truc qui se
vouent parce qu'elle a déjà joué ça l'an
dernier mais semble en fait elle avait
joué l'an dernier contre
1 et à nuire avait joué une variante qui
veut pensa surprise n était pas du tout
préparés et elle a perdu assez
rapidement donc quand elle est rouge
elle a rejoint cette variante je me suis
dit elle a dû préparer quelque chose
parce que c'est une variante où les
blancs sacrifie quand même deux pions
pour avoir du jeu donc j'avoue je
n'étais pas très très sereine de dos les
deux pions j'ai surtout l'impression que
je rentrais en plein dans sa préparation
ah oui mais bon parfois j'avais un peu
préparé comme j'ai dit j'avais surtout
préparer la française mais qui est quand
même un peu regardé cette variante
occasions mais c'est vrai que c'était un
peu
j'étais pas très sûr ne m'en étais pas
sûr j'attendais la surprise donc il y
avait déjà du stress dont clapotis rock
normal donc par contre petit rôle que tu
donnes le pius n
oui on donne des pions et 5 tout ça pour
gagner du temps de développement d'accor
donc là les mots reprennent en 5 et
maintenant logique tu prends et elle
prend ce qui fait que ce fou est exposée
au centre
oui je la connais eux qui quittent
ouverte bien sûr qu'on est ouverte
donc tu va l'occuper directoire attaque
le fou et donc on a déjà une tour en
face du roi pour un pion mais on se dit
après le coup suivant network à l'herbe
en effet si ce que tout ça est très
solide que on se dit comment les blancs
vont jouer là dessus habituellement lieu
de f6 les noirs juifs ou g7 et sur flu
g7
ouais on pour rire les foules en d4 on
pousse ans déclare tranquillement et on
sacrifie donc le second pion en donnant
sa danse dans cette partie là et elle
peut prendre du plomb 30 des pionniers
du fou mais après c'est ce qui a
toujours qui a aidé 5-fu g5 des
problèmes avec le pion 7 des problèmes
qu'avait ne veut pas sortir le fond on
s'évite est coincé enfin d'accord c'est
très compliqué donc là me joue f6 on
joue sur l'embouteillage des pistes
noires en fait donc là quand ella elle
l'a toujours pas utilisé de temps
attendu donc j'étais quand même un peu
un peu stressé parce que je me disais je
tombe en plein dans cette préparation
est donc mais bon tu connaissais déjà un
peu et il a fallu que tu trouves les
coûts sur l'échiquier aussi oui c'est ça
dames f3 beaucoup tu sors la dame
ouais j'en ai surtout ce qui est assise
b5 et qui alla turca vite qu'ils le
tuent en 17 et cloud et voilà la dame
ici bien sûr contrôler la grande
diagonale ici donc la tour à nice serait
en prison qu'à 2 à 6 baies 5
donc c'est déjà une façon de retarder
l'expansion des noirs le développement
de ce côté là le feu le pion 17 ans
cloué par le fou si on peut pas jouer ni
le pion béni le pion de tout ça ça se
développe pas et pour l'instant et puis
ce câble et a du mal à sortir parce que
six bien six on peut jouer le pion en
attaquant avec le fou je pensais
peut-être a qualifié ce comme cru quand
même malgré tout et sur des quatre qui
entre en d4 / t4
elle aurait pu faire puis on prend des 4
donc là il y avait une fois çi souka et
des 5
je pensais plutôt à faux et putschiste
je pensais plutôt un peu câbles et des
salles d'accord vous prend puis on prend
ces trois lots b normal oui oui et là
kellock tête retour d un tutorat des
tournées et continue et peut-être
envisager un sacrifice en 5 au site
oui des choses comme ça et puis il peut
y avoir des menaces sur f7 sur g7
non il ya quand même deux pions voire
peut-être trop pions en moins avec le
tueur b 2 mai
il ya beaucoup de jeu pour beaucoup de
jeux pour les blancs et safed et on a
donné beaucoup de matériel aussi donc
tout le monde enfin les normes
c'est le problème effectivement donc
d'un f3 et e6 voilà donc le joue aussi
cela donc pourquoi le joue aussi
certains amis je veux sortir lecavalier
n'a de sa soeur callian et cette wii et
faire petit rock donc là il faut réagir
vite pour les blancs sinon un joker et
ie 7 et si elle fait l'europe voilà
c'est ça le problème de cette position
et c'est là que ça va devenir hyper
tendu c'est que si les noirs se
développe cavaliers cette petit rock tu
vas quand même donné deux pions à venir
n'est qu'un fait un pion mais un pion
central donc le centre noir va devenir
progressivement très fort et tu vas te
faire écraser il est hors de question de
faire ça c'est que tu as donné un pion
c'est pour avoir de la vence de
développement comme on le voit là et
gêner au maximum le développement des
noirs et si possible lancé une attaque
en essayant d'ouvrir les lignes quoi ces
prêts est exact est déjà prête à ce
moment-là d'envisager un sacrifice en
fait oui oui quand j'ai joué quand elle
joue aussi souilah j'ai réfléchi j'ai
hésité d'abord à 3,5 et qualité qu'elle
a eu quatre oui ou sinon j'ai hésité
avec des 4 comprend des cadres comme
dans la partie comme dans la partie des
cas les gars qui quitte à avoir un tueur
envoie un second de suisse voilà je le
fous qui va arriver chez à tours 1 qui
arrivera aussi
voilà donc ça c'est faux et c'est
vraiment typique des partis qu'on
appelle romantique 19e siècle il y en a
eu beaucoup comme ça où les blancs et à
la fameuse l'immortel tu la connais ça
la wii 2 andersen qui donne quasiment
tous la dame poux et s'est mis à la
faille amat et là c'est un peu pareil là
tu donnes tout enfin tu donnes des pions
c'est pas tout mais c'est que ça fait
cher quand même si des pions sans trop
mais on voit que le développement des
bio des blancs se continue alors que les
noirs n'en est sorti à part le fou aux 5
et puis ça c'est à la maison le foot à
la maison la tour et a n'a évité la
torah 8 et à la maison c'est pas près de
sortir parce que sur 17 ne plia toujours
un clouage et on l'a vu sur l'a6b celle
qui a la torah 8 emprise donc c'est très
difficile pour les noirs en fait de se
développer c'est ça le lit des clés de
cette position mais il faut pas traîner
parce que il suffit que les noirs
arrivent à s'organiser un tout petit peu
pour rockets
un peu resserré les rangs et pouf ça
devienne tout de suite très difficile
donc d4 ton qu'aux actifs parce que les
noirs n'ont pas le temps de jouer un
coup de dé veloppement il faut il ya un
problème sur le phocéen donc si on est
obligé de prendre ceux ci prennent avec
le fou six points avec le goût d'avoir
le clan des éclopés donc en plus je te
retrouver six échecs et voilà déjà le
pion des est cloué par le faut donc pour
3 6 échecs et les blancs déjà savent que
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que la
colonie est ouverte parce que qu'est ce
qu'elle va jouer sans doute peut-être
cavaliers cavaillès 7 mai fu h6 il ya
plus de rock et donc ça va être entre
sectes les noirs sont des rockets ouais
bon il ya un pion toujours en moi mais
d'un homme plus en plus en moins mais on
voit très bien la casse des cinq ans et
sera le de quasiment sûr diagonale à 2
j'évite les pièces qui vont arriver
rapidement ne sais pas voilà donc il va
y avoir des gros gros gros souci pour
les pour les noirs il ya plus que la
tour alain pluss a rentré un jeu et
toutes les pièces blanches attaquent
l'euro et donc c'est vraiment donc c'est
pas bon il faut garder le fou au centre
on prend du plomb puisque le fourbe et
un fait barrière un petit peu vis-à-vis
du roi et c'est là que c'est là que date
à chaki et a donc un demi point à 2 de
la leader du championnat de france à une
route de la femme tranquille sur sa
chaise hyperconcentré pas de bruit
boum alors là elle nous fait tous trois
de cinq
c'est vrai que tu as déjà donné deux
pions maintenant tu donnes la qualité et
on peut pas dire tu es dans ta
préparation on est d'accord du tout tout
est là c'est de la pure
c'est à fully là ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas que de la feuille s'ils n'ont jamais
j'avais acheté un taux calculé ouais
j'ai vu que après entre 1,5 et régis
n'ont pu en principe on a quand même si
c'est possible oui je pensais faire tout
simplement tout reprend ici maintenant
tout reprendre aussi ça veut dire que
finalement tu prends quand même le pion
eux et comme tu as changé un fou contre
en cavalier tard une grosse attaque et
elle a rien c'est à dire que la paire de
fond voilà
ok je vois tir matour oui je prends en
d2 et j'ai affaire de fous sont rois est
au centre les colonnes sont ouvertes les
diagonales sont ouvertes
enfin ces genres des positions
compellent matériel oui oui et puis ça
va et puis là quoi mais là y'a rien donc
alors le seul truc pour sûr trop prendre
5 et sur le truc vraiment dangereux et
c'est ce qu'elle fait quand même bien
sûr très bien j'ai dit ah bon mais très
bien je prends tout le matériel j'ai les
deux pions j'ai la qualité c'est à dire
une tour j'ai pris une tôle contrefous
certes j'ai rien développé mais tu as tu
as intérêt à avoir une attaque qui fasse
mal parce que sinon après la finale elle
est complètement raide un avenir que les
noirs sont gagnants en finale donc là il
faut absolument que la taxe soit et
rendre m
on doit l'accepter at elle accepté le
challenge voilà vous avez relevé l'une
provenant que tant sacrifice est correct
c'est la relever le gant comme comme les
grands joueurs du passé là c'est
vraiment défi contre des filles donc ici
puis on prend 1,5
hélas le coup le naturel finalement
assez simple à jouer mais il fallait
suivre cette voie
et là tout de suite cavaliers ou quatre
ans j'avais un très bon coup est très
important ce fou qu'a l'air de rien il
super un super important ici en fait si
c'est grâce à lui que tous les dames ne
peut pas se fait une fausse manip là ici
voilà ce fou klaus au pian c'est très
important puisque tu peux sauter à tout
moment sur la case se dit ici ce qui
fait un échec notamment et qui
perturbent l'organisation des noirs par
exemple qu'elle ait des 6 3 e set fou
j'ai cinq échecs et la dame et quart du
ca patrizia la meuse des blancs
d'ailleurs pris donc là gilles ménage et
des menaces concrètes il ya une menace
directe donc problème pour les noirs
d'agir à ce moment-là nous qui commande
suit en direct un petit peu la partie
avec le grand maître ma meilleure amie
stella ont commencé à regarder les
coudes et noir il y en a pas beaucoup
beaucoup c'est à dire que c'est déjà un
problème on ne peut pas donc jouer à 6
pour essayer de stabiliser ce fouquet
des six l'allée des 6 3 c'est recettes
fou g5 et la dame est perdue puisque
dame aussi contrôler ici la cire gold
nef sur des coups comme par exemple
damas 5 voilà damas cinq à un seul coup
qu'on avait regardé aussi je pensais
soit fou des deux prix fous g5
alors oui les deux oui pas mal alors il
ya des imbéciles aussi peut-être pour
éviter fou des deux en fait je voulais
je pensais dire qu'ils ont joués 5 pour
la b6 fou j'ai symbole à mettons cette
variante la bombe
mais là c'est ugal du temps parce que tu
attaques là là elle peut pas prendre le
fou voyez parce que si la dame prend le
fourbe et sa cavalière des six échecs au
roi est là mais terni donc tous fous et
défendu mine de rien n'existe pas
défendu parce qu'il pouvait embêter sur
flu geste directement c'était peut-être
dam des 4 écrans la dame revenait en
hausse est à huy d'un bep 87 donc fou
des deux tomes psa et d'un v6 et l'autre
coup bien sûr est d'accord oui bien sûr
d'un v6 on évite food et 2 face à leur
transport parce que là je comptais je
vais fouiller ses droits la foulée 5
très bon coup donc tu avais déjà vu ça
il faisait savoir l'idée c'est qu'on
prend les cases noires on ne peut pas
prendre le fou à cause de calais des six
échecs bien sûr et là mais là c'est
carrément ces câbles et fils kevin 6
parce que sicav allait prendre dans
prend en menace mater on attaque la tour
en
très dur donc du coup jouer la dame sa
paire bon il reste peut-être dames 7 mai
sujet 5e g5 aussi longtemps là et le
coup qui a lavé l'art d'obtenir un peu à
6 h 6 h 6 pourquoi mais j'ai empêche gsm
voilà donc j'essaie de colmater le
problème c'est que voilà on a perdu
foucades noir donc il faut colmater les
cases noires en fait on joue au tour
prochain que j'avais déjà vu que sur hg
toujours la possibilité si j'étais
stressée de jouer cavalier des six
échecs dans cette position qui a des six
recettes recettes aidé à matran bien sûr
on l'a pas vue du maintien
ces conclaves à 3 et suroît et police je
fais dame f3 et je prends damas trois
regarder le problème c'est que le roi
peut pas s'échapper de l'échec la
découverte on sa menace cavaliers
prendrait cet échec et sagan adam et il
reste peut-être ça mais ça doit pas être
très bon en fait c'est un c secoue wall
et là hop hier j'avais toujours d'un f3
échec
voilà c'est ça ah oui répétition et je
pouvais toujours répété donc tu t'es dit
oui c'est vrai que c'est rassurant de se
dire bon quand qui à la mise si ça
marche pas je veux moi la nuit le coin
oui mais sûr il ya le coeur qui bat un
peu moins 8
un truc si peu mais il faut prendre une
décision
est-ce que je continue je vais pour le
gars bon et où est ce que je joue pour
est-ce que je prends la nuit et l
emplacement 3 5 ans sacrifient d'options
oui plaisir c'est tu te dis c'est
dommage
c'est dommage car elle ne peut rien
faire ni ni à la loi ni à la dame elle a
aucune pièce qui peut jouer alors là tu
as choisi le coup ici dame j'ai trois
dames les trois ans l'idée de la mg3
c'est d'attaquer à la fois eu 5 et
beaucoup je n'arrive pas je sais pas
c'est parce que je suis très gâté la
case f5
c'est bizarre je suis un peu coincé nage
pas pour toi là peut-être alors dame g3
voilà et tu attaques à la fois voilà le
pion le cercle et le pion jécistes alors
à noter qu'ici avait un autre coup qui
semblait bon qui a été vue plus ou moins
je crois c'est le voilà le coup
inattendu un peu b3 qui avait l'air pas
mal
l'idée c'est de tu peux toujours jouer
d'un endroit peut-être plus tard mais tu
vois là tu vas mettre le fou sur trois
jeux qu'on sait peut-être que damas
simple être un plus alors il ya des
avancées mais sur damas m tu peux encore
faire ton kung fu d2 et surtout décisif
où des quatre et sur dame v6 mais si tu
peux encore jouer éventuellement trouble
et 4 voire même pourquoi pas façon que
tu feras rien pour l'instant puisque
qu'avec des six échecs
donc tu peux aussi envisagée
ce pas madame j'ai trois quarts encore
jouable puisque tu menace de prendre que
j'ai six peut-être sauf que l'europe
peut être une caisse de fuite c'est
peut-être il ya aussi d'un os est qu'on
peut envisager ici bien sûr alors sur
damas 7 à 4 peut-être et le fou peut
ouais quand même venir là sachant qu'il
est toujours cloué ici et donc tu vas
gagner du temps sur la dame avec mon cas
les décisions c'est une possibilité je
ne sais pas du tout si ça c'est bien
j'ai aussi c'est pas sûr si j'ai pensé
parce que vu que le fou de cases noires
ne peuvent faire arriver sur la
diagonale mc alger 5 fallait trouver un
autre moyen de l'année oui d'accord dont
la diagonale à 3h it paraissait être
toujours en contrôlant la case des six
pad paraissait être un moyen tout à fait
mais même si après d'alger 3
je comptais pas prendre des plongées si
sa main qu'il comptait prendre le pion
aux cinq qui joue ff iv est bien
contrôlé les cases noires dacquois donc
là tu donc ce coup très bon a l'air très
bon aussi donc double menace insurgés 6
et sur re5
et à chaque fois c'est pas facile pour
elle a pas beaucoup de coups entre damas
est en fête imaginons que elle joue
comme il faut regarder et pour le public
la suit et qui comprend pas tout comme
nous comme moi je comprends pas tout est
donc ici cavaliers en 7 par exemple
bon ben je protège g6 alors c'est quoi
le problème ici sans doute que d'un
prince qui tout simplement d'en prendre
voilà par exemple en date la tour donc
il faut faire quelque chose parce que si
on récupère une tournette belle et blanc
sont gagnants tout simplement et surtout
réussi à hacker veille des six échecs et
mat et la matte bon mais voyez que ma
taille tout fait quasiment mais c'est ça
la met à l'étouffée donc voilà donc dame
j'ai trouvé que déjà il ya rajouté c'est
donc ça veut dire que pour chiens au cou
des morts les normes ne font toujours
pas de coup de dés de développement
mais c'est en train de subir
complètement en fait alors l'autre
solution peut-être c'est de protéger ça
on peut tenter d'amener cette admettons
damian certaines gdam d'un projet 6
alors cette fois là d'un projet 6 échec
au roi suivies d'oedèmes g7 et la tour a
chuté temps et en heure alors si le roi
vient des fuites
par exemple un peu plus compliquée la
main
encore jouer un peu peut-être non car ça
me paraît un peu long
il ya du jeu là oui je pense qu'il ya du
jeu peut-être pour en être de l'autre
côté par détroit voilà et maintenant
peut-être des trois marches la b3 avec
l'idée fou à 3 et si on veut des 6 ou à
croire quand même faut trois et on
pourra pas protéger des six salaire très
fort si les noirs mais ils peuvent rien
faire en fait pas empêché x 3 x 3
gagnants voilà tranquille il fallait le
voir ce coup quand même b3 ouais donc
dame g3 donc du coup le joug d'am-dam le
set
voilà qui tient si elles sont un nouveau
coup qui tient le mieux effectivement
donc là dessus poursuit maintenant par
alors tu va éliminer les pions se
trouvent déjà tu vas en récupérer 1
c'est déjà pas mal
parce que matériellement là tu as quand
même tour de moi j'ai une qualité d'une
qualité de moins une crise et c'est vrai
que si l'élection des deux pions et si
on récupère les pions c'est déjà moins
grave aussi et puis tu as toujours
l'attaqué donc ça commence à sentir bon
là parce qu'après dame prend 1,5
la tour est attaqué celui-là bon on
semble qu'ils aient perdu tôt ou tard
donc on n'est même pas pressés de le
prendre je voulais pas prendre depuis
angers 6e parce qu'après avoir noyé huit
l'europe où les cendres s'enfuir
oui adam était un peu était un peu
bloquée sur whip it oublie de t'oublie
d'enlever les cases noires horta besoin
d'enlever les classements pour libérer
ce fourmillement fou pouvoir ensuite
ramené la tour dans le jeu vous toujours
penser à la faux canton en attaque
même quand on attaque avec des pièces
comme ça très bien pensé aux autres
pièces qui peuvent arriver donc si on
peut en augmenter la pièce qui se joue
en attaque c'est plus facile de gagner
monsieur sur ce qu'elle appelle vraiment
de cloud et a pas de confusion on n'a
pas de coût voilà c'est ça d'un procès
elle n'a pas le temps en plus voilà
c'est ça à s'y attaquer là qu'est ce
qu'on fait on n'a pas le choix il ya un
seul coup je reste cette voie là ou
alors si dame f7 damage ses parrainages
cette belle option et c'est ce qu'il est
m me alors il ya ça par exemple voilà
imaginons damage 7 qui protège la tour
et qui donne un peu d'air au roi
peut-être ça libère des cases et là
alors donc là tu as des coups comme oui
j'ai d'un cran et six d'entre eux
ciseaux d'apprendre si nice ou super
année m'en fous d'impro 6 après trois
des huit tu vas tu vas être attaquée
quand même tu vas t'y vas perdre du
temps c'est pas grave tu penses on s'est
aggravée que le roi est au centre et
peut pas revenir aux recettes d'un
progressiste dame s'est agi d'un projet
si c'est toujours avec un proche hisse
encore avec un échec elle peut pas
courir de la dame est tout à fait alors
oui mais oui tu m'aimes damage 7
la dame est tout à fait celle d'amiens
pour je vais sur toral cèdre on se dit
c'est pas trop mal parce que la tour en
plus fait une défense latérale ici et on
se disait bon peut-être qu'on va pouvoir
s'en sortir là peut-être que dams et 7
est directement possible alors ou
peut-être cas d'amd vite alors dans
cette position le sens qu'on avait vu
des coûts possibles aussi à base deux
peut-être quelques ailes des six tout
simplement je crois et sur wade 8 parce
que royal fuite
pour ce problème toujours pareil avec b3
sans doute des x 3,1 des choses comme ça
et sinon sur wade 8 je crois il me
semble qu'on a vu tout simplement
d'apprendre des quatre avec l'idée de je
me trompe en fait c'est peut-être pas sa
tête réclament un l4 voilà après le fou
va venir en aide 4 et puis il est mort
tu vas en faire surtout n'ont peut-être
pas dans cette position
peut-être pas là ici vous êtes voilà
peut-être donc
ici donc on a vu un autre court que sous
ios 4 il me semble ici la chaussée à des
7 vallées d'ax et c'est tout un jour la
menace qui a aidé si c'est qu'elle prend
ses vitres du matériel oui voilà
dams et 7 lits des cavaliers chèque et
le finalement lequel cité perdue ne faut
pas oublier qu'on peut récupérer du
matos et si on récupère ça fait deux
pièces contre une tour déjà
matériellement c'est gagnant il attaque
continue en plus et là effectivement les
noirs je me suis dit ça doit faire enfin
j'allais vite sur a6 dames c'est cette
c'était sûr jouable plaisir année une
pièce en plus en attaque c'est mieux oui
il faut le rester tout est déjà peint
pas beaucoup de temps beaucoup de temps
mais elle peut encore défendre peut-être
part d'amd 8
le chauve comme ça peut-être cavaliers
qui est des six échecs ont calé des six
échecs quand même lorsqu'elle à leroy
viendra recettes pour continuer à garder
la dame est maintenant peut-être dame c5
menacer un échec le double et je pense
est quelquefois 1,4 c'était plus fort de
ralph naef 4 mais là je m'en fous des
monts foulée 5 n'est pas hacké par
action à 6 donc ce que te joue sam
gerber engins de toutes façons a donc
ici font f4 très bien on sort le fou
ainsi seul coup il faut il fait beaucoup
de clouer jouer pour les noirs n'y a pas
beaucoup d'autres coûts il faut essayer
de gîtes essayer de mettre les pièces en
jeu si on peut mounir espoirs en fait la
promesse à 6 et là tu vas juste tu as
fait le coup je t'aime c'est cette dame
c'est 7
alors donc donc t'as pas peur de plus on
prend sur qui on prend ya cavaliers des
six échecs que les décisions et chèvres
oies f8 c'est fluide forcé je pensais
qu'elle est peut-être mais jouer ce
hacker français vite c'est que les
pensées huit attaques la dame et menaces
ou silésie c6 peut-être surtout france
et vite
elle pouvait jouer tout reprend ses
listes pour concéder remettra en service
en prend
à f 7 on essaie tout simplement d'un
prend 17 et je vais ramasser les pions
ll dame toujours le client des quatre
certainement et jeu pousser le cuir en a
et le plan à madame et a déjà égalisé le
matériel l'état position est devenu
super lui envoie 100 kg g8 et sa tour h7
qui tranquille le contenu joue pas donc
dames c'est cette dame des 8
c'est ça la donc tu fait qu'elle ait
décidé et 6 pour le set
donc c'est d'avoir un combat commençait
à voir d'ailleurs sauf que le fou est en
effet quatre jeux étaient encore plus
tranquille quoi là c'est très très bien
protégé alors l'amener à 6,6 et
cavaliers prend fou ainsi chacun à noter
que dame b6 marche pas parce que la dame
ait perdu de toute façon dont ça c'est
pas bon les mêmes il ya un échec double
ici un échec de voilà il ya aussi un
échec double quand on prend à ses huit
ya échec du cavalier et de la dame donc
là c'est dur c'est vrai que la dame
c'est ça alors là le problème c'est ce
qu'on habite à l'heure aussi une
possibilité peut être c'est d'essayer de
sortir de l'échec tout simplement bravo
fou aux 5
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le roi si on
revient là bas on va se prendre par
exemple qu'elle allait prendre 17 et la
dame ait perdu 20 de ce truc
ou alors s'il aura bientôt le g5 c'est
sans doute un at il ya un match certains
qui y est d'apprendre et catherine
jourdan prendre b4 ça suffit je prends
voilà on menace matongé 4 aux menaces
aussi d'amérique quatre-roues h5 g4
quasi d'alger 4
mais c'est vrai ça va vite madame g4
matin déjà on voit mal comment
si on joue à 100 pour empêcher la ja
matin r4 voilà donc c'est seimat donc
d'un mécène dams et 5 déjà 60 quand même
hein ça sent pas bon pour les noirs ici
là
il est blanc une position archi crainte
c'est quand une super partie là ces
sacrifices
donc là elle joue b5 b6 donc y aller
chez double il ya aussi dame b 4 qui
était possible il ya aussi dans b4
simplement voilà sur dam leca très chaud
juste 3 f 6 et maintenant web 6 mais tu
peux prendre des quatre avec la dame en
chine oui et puis sur trois recettes
revenir en b 4 est un tueur vient après
et ensuite sur m6 et a déjoué tout
retour un point qui me restent floues 5
avec une opposition là aussi écrasante
donc sur bécistes a choisi toit de
prendre ces huit alors le problème c'est
qu'après prise dans ces huit alors le
câble et va reprendre le pion c'est ça
il peut toujours reprendre le pion mais
si je voulais garder je peux avoir les
deux les deux pièces pour la tour avec
toujours les dames en jeunes qu'est ce
donc tu choisi cette variante la cavale
et prend ses huit maintenant échec
double alors sur un échec double on n'a
pas le choix il faut que le roi bouge
ici droit f7 et là tu es revenu échec ce
qui sauve déjà le cavalier que le joue
donc ici projet set et après le simple
tu aurais pu faire aussi d'apprendre des
quatre ici on fait sur ensuite dame
oui j'aurais dû dam des quatre détroit
et puis hop qui doit ce que c'est si
simple
déjà les deux blancs sont déjà gagnants
alors que chose parce que davantage doit
me prendre des quatre secteurs relève la
menace sur la dame puis après tu sauves
le fou et puis bon on compte les pièces
stade de foot contre le tour est une
attaque qui continue mais je voulais
peut-être je vais garder les dames dur
d'en prendre quatre peut-être joué
dernier 6 gagneriez food inc ah oui faut
5 c'est vrai mais je l'avais en plus
c'est très dur labeur de langue pour les
noirs et encore on en voit pas tout les
vendre parce qu'on n'a pas le temps mais
je vous assure et où regarder cette
partie sur les défenses il ya des
attaques extraordinaire c'est une partie
modèle à étudier cela si vous voulez
apprendre la tactique vous allez voir
c'est fou on regarde que quelques
variantes ça serait trop longue
on dirait qu'on en a vu quelques-unes
aussi avec sébastien mazet qui vous avez
rejoint d'ailleurs c'est bien mu est
donc issifou 1 5 échecs pas mal c'est
bon endroit et fuite le le roi se remet
sur higuain mais attention la dame et
attaquer donc mais surtout faire
attention délicate les dames b4 dont la
dame b4 donc alors qu'est ce qui se
passe bien sûr maintenant admettons
qu'elle prenne le fou n'a par exemple
pas ce que j en récupère le matériel
quoi mais non mais à ce qu'il y ait
baisse est en fait on se caille et b cet
échec
macadam et sur dame 7 donc attaque la
découverte le cavalier attaque la dame
tout en ayant un échec faut parer
l'échec il faudrait sauver la dame on
peut le faire avec dams est tout va bien
non on va tu en as food et 6 2 et
c'était important d'avoir de ramener le
fou est un jeu qui cloue la dame et
voilà donc ce fou qui était venu au f4
voyez pourquoi il est important c'est
que la voilà ça ici cloud est donc
terminée on gagne la dame
c'est très beau masque quand j'avais
envisagé dames c'est cet objectif au f4
fizi c'est toujours mieux d'avoir le
font toujours toujours sur b2 pièces en
attaque mais c'est bien sûr parce que
j'allais rater cavaliers 7 47
c'est pour ça que j'ai joué faux 5 et
madame prend des 4 j'avais complètement
j'ai pas vu que sur la food & 3 elle
veut tout simplement qu'elle et ses six
pattes avait peur de food est trop à huy
qui attaquent double jean la dame et le
cavalier à oui il y avait une petite
petite astuce ici sur food et 3 il ya un
petit truc là c'est effectivement
cavaliers c6 alors oui non c'est bon ça
a l'air bien ça qu'elles les c6 oui elle
et ses cités et donc c'est embêtant
parce qu'évidemment la dame est attaqué
le fou et on peut pas jouer la dame on
protège en fout donc si on s'assoit
encore oui oui donc damien alors c'est
peut-être une borne qu'on a vu
d'ailleurs ça il me semble et damien la
fin et au reste de pièces contre roye
plus la tac qui continue donc sa caisse
et 6 mai jeunes et c'est pour ça que je
fous d'être à jouer x 4 d'accord donc
que dans deux jours il faut quatre à
quatre et pourquoi pas le x 4 au lieu
des trois là pour contrer cassé sinon
tout à fait d'accord et là je menace
aussi d'un prend des quatre tout
simplement est de ramasser incluant
aussi bien sûr qu'il donc la b5 effectue
enfin se fout bon et qu'elle aurait bien
aimé faire plus tard mais n'a jamais pu
fait plutôt donc la fougue et trois ont
déjà les blancs sont beaucoup mieux
voyez hein
si vous comptez les pièces il ya
cavaillé contre cavaliers dames contre
dame tour contre tours il reste une tour
contre deux fourreaux deux fous c'est
beaucoup plus fort qu'une tour ont déjà
deux cavaliers en général ça peut être
aussi plus fort qu'une tour fouet
cavaliers aussi mais que parfois c'est
un peu difficile mais deux poussées
contre le beaucoup plus de casque puis
tour avec deux fous beaucoup plus
puissant vous êtes donc ici qu'à blesser
6 quand même voilà préféré me laisser
avec fougue et l'allier piste au cac a
perdu fond elle a raison
oui il y aura stratégique commun c'est
mieux donc dame csn tranquille sur la
biologie et la cavale et prend donc elle
élimine justement un des fous mais ça
suffit pas on va pour tout de suite
après d'un point c'est ce pion est perdu
et locales et des six il est en plus
très très pénibles
il reste pénible oui et il empêche les
tours de communiquer entre elles ouais
garde en tuant 17 mais elle s'accroche
un sacré choc la petite andreya d'un v6
donc elle essaie de maintenant d'essayer
de d'activer un peu ces pièces après
avoir souffert voyez tout ce
développement peut-être aidé à 9,6 et
directement possible alors dame f6 ici
bien sûr possible échec alors il n'a pas
le choix à roye g8 d'un projet 6 ou
peut-être voir s'il ya pas des thèmes
avec il faut prendre
oui parce qu'on voit que la dame en v6
n'est pas protégé donc il suffit de
bouger le cavalier en faisant un échec
pour gagner la dame sur gazon
effectivement
compliqué effectivement pourrait
envisager ça aussi regarder fou prend
qui on prend dames 3 or si le roi va sur
place des chèques du cavalier par
exemple ont ensuite il ya 400 ans
j'essaie d'être cavaliers aux 8es la
dame prend la dame donc le seul autre
coup c'est de jouer en 8 es là peut-être
un simple tour eu un et on menace
peut-être aussi un peu aussi je vais
peut-être de 9,6 on peut peut-être aussi
rejouer la dame en uf6 lequel que alain
gelly c'est peut-être prendre des pions
g6 ici on prend quand même le cloud
justice en dehors et là attention on
peut parler ensuite à cause de cabaye et
7 et 6 tours joue dame s dans
l'industrie en courant au cices ont bien
h7
et il faut encore travailler layada mme
aida me 4 et 2004 oui c'est vrai dans le
400 réussi à tour g6 et tu prends à 8
mais tu vas pas d'accord tu vois par le
cavalier là donc c'est plus compliqué
quand même parce que tu as fait non j'ai
préfère comme total ac le feu f4 préféré
ramener la tourte sont les noirs ils
peuvent pas peuvent pas bouger
c'est beaucoup mieux bien sûr je ramène
la dernière pièce qui n'était pas en jeu
oui dans l' attaque
oui puisque je dirais pédagogiquement
parlant mais là on est 28e coup nous
rajouter de faim à andrea lui reste cinq
minutes à 16 minutes
oui je voulais pas rentrer dans des
complications j'ai une position qui est
stratégiquement gagnante et je vais
récupérer pions des quatre voilà au pire
je pensais jouer ses trois fous c2 et c3
fous ces deux attaquants il faut que
j'attaque tranquille et puis la tour
arrive aussi encore bien sûr c'est
l'arrière la pièce blanche en jeu il ya
déjà avantages matériels pour les blancs
et non les noirs
ça sert à rien de rentrer dans des
complications initie lonza et notent
tout à fait nouveau assuré le point
exactement à 3,7
à noter qu'on est au 28e coup quand tu
disais qu'il se retirait du voile 12
coups avant d'avoir un rajoutant donc il
faut quand même jouer des coups assez
vite on croit aux 7 qui est normal mais
tout reprendre simplement à protéger
tout en sortant enfin la tour et toutes
les pièces blanches voyez joue là
maintenant c'est presque une formalité
on va dire
on peut dérouler les coûts avec toi
fuite il faut rester vigilant parce que
bon c'est vigilant on voit quand même
que l'option f2 et sous les rayons de
soul attaques de la dame b6 et et la
tribù fou d'ailleurs je crois qu'on l'a
vu sébastien mazet qui a vu ça il ya
très beaucoup de natacha effectivement
tour et 4 très fort regarder ça à l'air
de rien l'idée c'est que si les noirs
prennent la tour les cavaliers ans et
huit échecs au grand gala dame et si la
dame prend le cavalier est tout
simplement un homme prend dames et après
on va prendre de la tour et suit est
perdu donc ce coût est très fort puisque
aucune des prises n'est possible et sur
un compte en banque sur tours h à trith
alors sur ici tour à slash ou huit qui
protège la tour en ville en échange des
tours tout simplement simplement
échanges ici oui on peut pas prendre du
roi parce que tout autant prises il faut
reprendre de la tour des dames g7 et en
n'guessan plus d'âme g7 on peut pas
courir de la tour ciel cavaliers et
après dame prend votre roi se rendre par
des cavaliers
on prend la tour et on à foot+ dans une
finale techniques faciles à la même
façon c'est une caisse en fusion que
nous l'étions ventes ont décelé ce net
donc ici tout g8 elle joue je l'aï lu ce
coin
défense autour g8 on a eu aussi envisagé
tourache 8la l'autre tour mais bon ça
change pas grand chose
là on approche de la fin un très joli
coup là de retrait pas mal bien cavalier
e 4 on garde le contrôle sur les cases
ici donc oui et non mais à 7 prendre le
cavalier en d6 oui bien sûr et
maintenant on voit que la dame feu
rentrée en réussissant un f6 évidemment
m6 et et les noirs sont quasi totalement
raid tu vas même peut-être des fois
d'état les sacrifices en cours en russie
où il y en a plein le plein de thèmes
tout marche ont tous rêvent cette menace
est d'alléger un peu la pression en
échange d'une tour qui n'hésite pas tout
reprend rois princes et qu'alexis
attaque la tour et à ta création des ces
attaques le pion de 17
nokia pas le choix pour les noirs ici
tour des huit protection faut encore
finir la partie calais g4 est bon
puisque ça attaque à la fois un chien si
c'est ça ta madame de rentrer en voilà 6
donc je lis aura la manoeuvre du
cavalier et elad hop hop hop
tranquillou assez joli angers 8
et voilà très fort 2006 ce qu'il faut
c'est que je joue encore des coûts et
faire la toilette wind on attendait pas
tant c'est vrai on menace de gagner tous
les pions et avec le cavalier le matin
et elle peut pas protéger puisqu'il bien
sûr ce rouage 7 qui a damé schéma c'est
la partie un orage 7 dans le vii
moi je suis tu es le tournoi oui
mal cela salit et cavaliers 6 avec le
matin en âge cet imparable
superbe voilà vous avez vu comme ils
attaquent extraordinaire sortes
d'émotions deux pions une qualité
et puis vous pas faire toutes les
variantes y en a plein et des subtiles
qu'on a pu voir avec des gains bon c'est
quand même beau mais c'était beaucoup
d'émotion on suppose pour toi est aussi
pour nous parce que on se demandait on
se demandait ce qui se passait c'était
quand même surtout par rapport aux
premières tables par rapport au fait que
tu es maintenant en tête du championnat
probablement son fumier va faire
peut-être nul est encore au moment où on
parle en sais pas peut-être pourrait
perdre aussi malgré qu'elle ait fait une
bonne partie en année ça s'est retourné
on sait pas encore le résultat
donc il est possible probable que tu te
retrouves en tête du championnat de
france à une rente de la fin alors que
tu as déjà joué les favorites en plus
c'est herta déjà enfin il reste quand
même s'il ya joué qui oui mais si je
vais maigreur ça oui mais qui n'est plus
en course pour le titre quand même oui
mais elle est à 13 ans elle est pas très
loin d'être et avec les incontournables
gênés nord avec les noirs alors bon pas
mal quand même moment oui ça je fais un
très bon tournoi
ouais espérons que ça continue de vingt
cinq victoires à finir ça c'est le poids
ne fixant quatre victoires et un forfait
mais ça fait 5 points donc ça fait c'est
du lycée rares o 6 1 4 2 tours d'affilée
c'est quand même c'est bien donc il faut
éviter l'emballement aussi parce que
comme a dit mon frère on est encore
voilà on est encore loin d'un pic mais
le canton gagnant gagnant gagnant on
peut après prendre trop de risques aussi
ils sont embarqués dans des choses peu
trop risqué oui ça peut arriver mais la
ceinture à toute ronde faut aussi se
dire que si la position est égal il faut
respecter ce que la position de monde
aussi
c'est la position également la position
est nul ça ne sert à rien de forcer le
gain moyen de forcer prendre le risque
elle estime qu' on verra demain on
suivra bien sûr ta partie avec grande
attention de même ce sera une des deux
parties importantes ce national féminin
2016 à agen donc c'était la deuxième
fois que le natacha nous rejoignent et
sur le studio diagonale tv pour une
deuxième magnifique partie peut-être
peut-être la plus belle partie du
national cette année bien qu'il y avait
quelques unes aussi pas mal hein et
celle là elle est vraiment magnifique
mais faut être deux pour faire une belle
partie oui je crois qu'on peut aussi
saluer la ténacité d'andrea qu'à essayer
bon mais de faire de tenir au maximum
puis de poser des problèmes aux blancs
en encaissant le matériel et en relevant
le défi
voilà parce que sinon on n'aurait
peut-être pas eu une partie aussi aussi
belle merci beaucoup d'attachés merci
stéphane merci de nous avoir suivi sur
le studio des gonades tv pour cette
magnifique partie donc entre natacha
benzema et andré y en a vanté ce coup je
donne rendez-vous pour une prochaine
partie à bientôt hors bord